well well it's whiskey Wednesday its
dude it's whiskey Wednesday you'll have
Japanese whiskey here I got so now I
want to put my nuts on your nose
yep I know he do and I understand I
wanna see you put your nuts on it
somebody's nose is that weird you know
long nuts yep and I want to see him
dribbled dry not ceremony seem drizzled
like chocolate and syrup on a sundae
almost you nuts drizzled on some poor
young like my nuts are made to cover the
human nose and we know this Kansas City
if you want to see my nuts April 30
what's getting result in Kansas City if
you want to get my nuts my nuts made to
cover the human nose Kansas City April
3rd and 4th come see my nuts I will be
wearing them on the outside of my jeans
Columbus Ohio I'll be wearing my nuts in
the outside our jeans April state of
[ __ ] jam here Charlotte comedy zone
and gamma-iron Charlotte North Carolina
whoa April 23 24 26 on the outside my
dreams of hangin brain bump see them put
them on you know eat whatever you want
to go and hang your brain then you're in
Denver my hometown I'm in Atlanta you
Fox Friday bucket theater 100 tickets
left New Orleans Saturday night papa
need some help New Orleans Dark Arts
come on down New Orleans Fillmore
Atlanta so Atlanta's Friday New Orleans
Saturday come on down tea fat K calm out
you listen if Brian's getting his nuts
out I'm getting my nuts out I'll be full
of Japanese whiskey and throwing some
[ __ ] jokes your way Austin next week
Thursday Friday Saturday March 19th
through the 21st capcity those were
almost sold out then I in March in
Toronto one night only might add a
second show it's about March 26 run Oh
March 27th Detroit then I end March in
Minneapolis theater that's almost sold
out March 28th in Minneapolis and then
April gets [ __ ] froggy your point
scared of Corona because I'm jumping
across the pond Cork Ireland is April
15th
Belfast April 16th Dublin - shows April
17th
Glasgow UK new Cass Gilbert Newcastle
Newcastle is April 20th Birmingham April
21st Manchester April 23rd London Oh
- April 24th Cardiff April 25th and then
Amsterdam April 29th and I end in New
York City Gramercy Theatre May 7th and
8th those are almost sold out get tix
now t fat k calm for Brian and myself
touches nuts let me know what you think
but Atlanta Friday and [ __ ] New
Orleans Saturday t FATCA calm also new
thick boy merch and we got [ __ ] sweet
tart tart and a Smerch spicy hoodies we
got it all the new merch store is poppin
liddie like a [ __ ] titty y'all thick
boy sweaters thick boy t's sweet tartar
nasties fine kid tees get it all T fat K
calm like it's a very nice whiskey
this is sixpence that's 23 years old
this is 23 this is this one 7 this is
age 79 I'm talking about that Bushido
all [ __ ] oh well Bushido whoa do you
know who she domains in samurai it were
your way of the warrior warrior Bushido
and you know I'm a samurai now let me
see simmer these mo
Makoto Mayo Makoto I feel you have to
end you have to Makoto you know it's a
very much oh very good whiskey Japanese
nice Japanese make a beautiful way they
sent a 2923 age 23 a 17 and a 10 damn
this is not very good what am i drinking
right now you're drinking the 1700
cheeto series as good as I've ever had
and I'm not joking I'm drinking it right
now essentially on an empty stomach and
no and I'm drinking it neat and it's
delish it's Sona might get a little
drunk just for the [ __ ] well this is
primary third shot now stuff oh it is
and I'll have a nicotine patch in so hey
be cool be why are you doing Nick oh
cool I've been to a nicotine cuz helps
with your brain
hey Jackson I didn't know that who's
Jackson I'm calling you Jackson right I
don't know why
oh yeah that's and smooth you know I did
say it broke my own rule we can't smooth
all right I'll take that
Jackson smooth let me out yeah I had a
very good whiskey you've had a Cano nips
will know chin chin too good Paul chin
Ezek feelin as well [ __ ] is going on
with you
guys never to me I get to Shawnee Okla
rhythm you saw neo kratom I bought yeah
we did that too yep now so but first of
all i'm sonica and i kk Nika Nika
whiskey it's my favorite whiskey they
have a coffee grain whiskey I'm no
coffee in it I'm a huge fan of this
whiskey so I was talking about
Nika whiskey then these boys Bushido
The Mikado Japanese whiskey oh hey you
like that I think we do it better can we
send you a package I went send it bro so
you see what this and they sent it and
this [ __ ] is Fanta it's called Mikoto
single grain whiskey it is a strength we
gotta open the a strain three it's it's
bourbon cask matured by kumis and
axillary this [ __ ] is no joke dude it's
no joke
welcome can you see how much this costs
for the 23 year old hope it hey open the
Internet's our weekend hammering hey oh
ha ha $23 dude I believe it it's as good
as it can help damn Oh [ __ ] dude that's
a crazy expense hey Mikoto please send
me a bottle hey I'm a whiskey drinker
I'm a whiskey drink if they don't hate
it
hey hey don't do it I'm gonna badmouth
hey you know I'm a gentleman I said I
drink whiskey yeah I'm gonna start
drinking with her too and I'm glad you
brought this up because hymns told me to
that I keep until Brian quit saying god
dammit dude come on man like you don't
be mean bro that's not it so interested
I tasted and I was like let's be open
that up oh oh you thought this was a
game Papa loves a game no dude I'm
always he kind of sore Oh Paul I getting
out my shows whatever reason Branson
with you in green rooms just that is
with whiskey that is the best whiskey
I've ever [ __ ] had in my life I'm not
trying I mean this isn't us I'm not we
have no not a sponsoring this is the
best whisky Murtagh was God I am
hey I need I need a bottle of that at 23
or hey dude look at me
we'll see I'm a gentleman I'm an older
gentleman and strew drinks whiskey Jack
hey Jackson smooth neck smooth no no
Jack Smith Jack Smith let me ask you
something I'm open this up yeah do that
I had simi fangirl over a guest before
like Marc Maron it's great not funny
that's great you have no idea I loved
that man huh he's earned it he's earned
it been around been in the game a long
time very smart yeah he's such a monster
I am carrying everything okay Murch show
whiskey are you enjoying the whiskey to
work are you enjoying it yeah hey thanks
guys
can you give it to me in that class yeah
Brendan gave me this
that's Chen's glass if he was going to
let you use it for today no no what's
right try it yeah I know
reading the hot sound about the archives
of the Ebola virus very interesting what
happened
oh god it's another thing but your
stylus it's just so that was the Whiskey
in there didn't want his whistle well hi
because I want I wanted to be I want to
taste the 2000 right now I'm gonna get
there you go no no it did say it's
contaminated by the whiskey Sam oh you
use your sock
soak it up with your sake oh my god you
just bounced you so worried about corona
last night we're all sitting around
having a good time after doing stand-up
at the store right I love your time
Kalen starts going on this Rees gonna do
it on there this rant about Ebola thank
you
if it aint Corona I'm not trying to hear
it well but it's wait do you hear the
horrible stories he tells us about Ebola
how it you throw up and it's looking for
a hose to come out of your ass and it's
black tar isn't it nice do Japanese make
some of the best whiskey nice to be
super anti what no dude be cool do you
have to go back to work out this
good we need some food oh you want pizza
just kidding I wish I order something I
can't unless I can delete me
what can we pop a woke up today six
pounds down six pounds down on the
carnivore diet my face yeah you and you
extremists look good when you die
blasted it was good I I broke my rule
today hold on let me just taste this now
goddamn you broke your goddamn is good
god damn it's good whiskey what a nose
oh yeah the Ebola virus okay bring up
let me see the reading that let me read
this company real quick though you know
my my boys a Buffalo Trace that's who I
always [ __ ] with my been on this
Japanese probably this is the best Java
Caesar now hold up I've been really into
Japanese and I never liked their cars
I like the [ __ ] Godzilla GTR other
than that get the [ __ ] out of my face oh
nice Nissan G that's by far I'm not away
I call it imported that is insanely good
that is so smooth mmm [ __ ] this
this blows Pappy Van Winkle oh [ __ ] oh
happy Van Winkle this is all harbor to
the coronavirus a Pappy Van Winkle
I listen to the the a disease expert I'm
Rogan I'm still like wait why do you do
the entire show like this well he did
trust her eyes eyes oh she's no man we
might have yeah he has my eyes ten years
from now twenty our list oh yeah your
eyes are so much better yeah he but he's
you know here's the thing when you have
an infectious disease expert they see
everything as danger it's just like
talking to somebody who's a surgeon
they're gonna wanna cut you know is like
talking to a dark cloud yeah cuz he sees
the worst of the worst
yeah and so he gets on Rogen sets the
[ __ ] since the whole [ __ ] castle
on fire well that when I'm in this hot
zone look Mikado whiskey was distilled
1995 was aged 23 years you're welcome
Brian you know bourbon Cass it's level
of complicity high praise by whiskey
kind of stores all over the world
any whiskey Collective who's in Bushido
the unwritten samurai code of conduct
Mikado
you know the unwritten samurai class
samurais drink whiskey whatever I don't
think they drink any of Mikado is the
principle after whiskeys with the view
of Corrado as our inspiration Wow
well Cheers it's a beautiful whiskey you
don't drink it out of disrespect long to
crack it hammered that's fantastic isn't
that beautiful
what would you say about the bottle
please don't drink it out of a bottle
Papa's this is what I do dude hey smooth
jack treats out of a bottle smooth jack
drinks it out of a bottle
Jackson smooth drinks out of the bottle
is that true wow that's impressive
God your whiskey company should be
called Jackson smooth but how the [ __ ]
do you compete with that
mmm-hmm Kat was actually there and heard
the plant in San Diego you thinking
about starting your own whiskey Tara
it's always something in it I'm too into
whiskey why wouldn't I I'm too into it
why wouldn't I do dude maybe they could
do like a Last Samurai whiskey you know
Tom Cruise is like the last white white
samurai yeah I could do that for Bushido
let's get ya
last night was fun it was great just
hanging out I texted Chris afterwards
cuz we were acting like such idiots and
I said I loved me is there anything
better than being idiots together like
that is there anything better than all
of us hanging out Rogan was in rare form
Tullio everyone out we're all great I
came the greenroom hot is that a great
set upstairs and the bellies came in you
came in in a loose shirt you look like a
slacker
yes whoa first thing Chris and I said
what are you trying to not look like a
giant you trying to not look right and
then we were in that private bar and I
looked over and saw a guy who did to do
two dwarfs you sure do more legs a
bigger shirt that's actually whatever
his tasks were but his loot eyes were
huge he was he was a very big boy bigger
than mr. pelt Obama they were no Baba
and can I tell you where he was bigger
and I'm sorry to say this to you don't
go dick I'm sorry to say he's no my
dick's bigger hold on take it easy
you're a little jealous that guy and I
understand why I tend to the dealers
he's a good-looking too
it's a good-looking cat with a knack
ring him up chin with a nice
good-looking dude phenomenal football
player died peace girl
yep genes work for me very difference
for me to type for Brenda but he's got
he had typed in Japanese what you don't
have and I'm out I'm a shock on your
body Japanese denim fan of your body
Bubba you love my mama fine fan your
Papa's down six pounds I know Papa but
listen can i Papa listen go ahead honey
are you getting all crazy already here
you're weird I've never seen you
insecure about this now relax me papa
listen the kid the kid had put started
the kid had a rich Steve Hawking had
some ham II saw him yeah NASA and an ass
on it and here's the thing stylish but
no his shirt was ridiculously oh you
talk about the crush velvet black shirt
but I kinda pulled it off no come on Dan
McDonald yeah I don't know big white kid
the hide a dead boy for not there is I
don't know hold on I don't know if
that's him nope that's not him let's go
back there play jacks cause the France
free agent now honey bout all he's a no
reason tie that Gentry go to Zach Gentry
it's cuz he's accident that's weird
yeah he was talking to Jasmine yeah it
was make sense cuz both Pittsburgh are
they big a big white guy maybe him I
don't know let me see no he had a sharp
face on him yeah a sharp face with the
stylist here that was him Bubba I swear
to god that's not him Brent I promise
you that's not him a Sherpa no that
might be him Papa it might be Annie grew
his beard
yeah that's not him dude it was him I am
I'm almost positive as him yeah but
starting any well type in football
player of the dwarfs Brennan you're
lucky Kelsey didn't show up Travis Kelce
Swiss come last night to watch your boy
yeah
you're lucky he didn't come cuz you look
like a turd with Iceland well I know I
do and that's what straight nine you
always say to me I'm not even that big
and I and I got [ __ ] and then I see
those guys do that all the time
oh my god you know what I want to do I
want to rip your [ __ ] off because as
soon as mayor comes in you know I'm
self-conscious my athletic ability yeah
and a suit coming your Brennan's an
athlete yeah you know I'm never going
32000 oh no well I mean you will cause
already talked to him about you on the
on WTF when I did it still do yes it's
fine you oh my god that's Nick all right
Nick for net that's him
dude yep that's it here he is Perry is
connect cat who's Barry is hat who's
better-looking you gotta see you in
person cat nope type you got a see him
in person at the end of the day this kid
is no joke do this and I hey I'm sorry
I'm sorry they're all right it hurts my
feelings I'm bummed out
I'm sorry I know you're upset I don't
blame you he played the same position
there's some [ __ ] going on with you
right now and I get it I've never seen
you like this I was like if you got [ __ ]
back in college I know you are but you
leave a tight end you're in high school
will you play T I didn't you play T
weren't you gonna try to be drafted in
the NFL ta they maybe I was a full bag
HVAC dude but then they made you a Titan
no you can yell twice okay I don't
that's public okay I don't know what's
he waitin he's just such a big he's a
beast hall hall six to six to sixty
sixty bollocks feel like he was taller
than that I don't know he's definitely
sit yeah schools okay plan oh ha state
that's Oh
you know what I've seen that man played
ball and he's a hell of a player yeah
player Rama [ __ ] look so big and
weirdly strut like so big I was like
well yeah I mean you obviously are doing
that all the time yeah cuz we're around
other convenience right I mean I'm a
ginormous man yeah for an NFL players
you're kind of regular your man but no
no no norm normal well I mean no one's
smaller well well er you'll see heavy
weight I'm sure your yes dude like those
guys are huge yeah yeah he's a stout now
you might be you might be as strong as
he is you're very strong right he's no
[ __ ] I remember playing in college
he's a stud yes girls at diaries girls
beautiful but but you're you're were you
and without being without Brad right
that is he is hot right maybe that's the
fans what would you say that would you
say cuz I've heard from Lauren Lando
you're you're as strong as most NFL what
would your train does this say give me
his combine numbers what are you doing
to combine numbers yeah go type in Nick
then at the duty plateau house state
that's been so good yeah he's such a
stud
yeah good would you type in combine
numbers I scroll down
well active player in the NFL I mean you
can scroll down from our comment sense
yeah so I ran a four or five eight
vertical 29th I'd jump higher bronze up
95 I did more than I is that true
yep okay here's the thing he's way
better at football what did you run what
did you run a 40 in I like the slow turn
four six that's very quick for a man
your size I don't know I tell dick jokes
and it doesn't help out for six is no
Joe Lord Lando right now well are four
six eight Brian
Lauren Landau said they're stronger than
this Brennan shopping because the
strength goes around the front
he's a strength he said in Cary NC right
he said that you carried a hundred
pounds in each hand for like five
minutes or something and beat all the
lineman okay it's not a big deal
everything on his protein but here's the
here's the idea here your we're strong
here think he's a really really good
foot
he's I know who he is he's phenomenal
and devoted he's so much fun sure okay
all right all right well dude
all right cross velvet shirt wasn't
feeling it but maybe he's filled now in
at us and at us up in a tussle up you
talk about it you know you know you guys
get he gets anything goes a bro you know
I saw you looking at my girl
don't look at my girl and gives you a
shove around sure gives you a shove her
yeah what about it you talk about in the
common story that closed bachelor bar
you take him into deep water
well not that deep of water but he might
be known I know pop it's me the shallow
end oh really
it's me the shallow but he might be the
girl on jaws and you pull him under what
happens he doesn't know what's going on
yet doesn't don't bring it out dude
that's a lie Anansi cool dude you've got
a language you language you fluent a
knife you can't Spall's the tough guy
big athlete phenomenal but he's a
phenomenal football but now but now and
he looks dope there he was this thing
take a great white out of water to now
he's got some problems he can flap he
can flop around Pappas good on land and
sea here's the [ __ ] dude hey Rowley and
hey surf and turf he's safe return I'm
surfing to surf and turns different turn
yeah surfing interface yeah so you're
not hearing him be badass surf and turf
what do you want water land bro so
you're not hearing a beep out of him
hahahaha then he goes hey Papa failed
NFL player well you played no game hurt
your feelings know that all your
nostrils flare you get a little vein in
your neck no no wrong okay I know what
you know he's such an amazing that yeah
when I even comparable it's okay he was
starting tight in for Ohio State the
biggest football University on the
planet and also my favorite college
outside University of Colorado
here's the thing Papa Nick thanks every
boy here fashion guy like you tight is
out tight so out tight jeans are so it
didn't mind his jeans I was in foul them
look at him there he looks like he looks
like he looks like a thicker Aaron
Rodgers right there he looks good there
he looks like there handsome fellow he's
a handsome girl is a [ __ ] into did dot
that died she's a 10 she's a 10 listen
you don't catch footballs for the buck
guys and not get your dicks up well
there he is I know he's he's the alpha
male that's fine he's the ease the apex
alpha do you think he's like look at his
leg I'm alright I hate I hate this
this conversation oh it's a bummer Fang
hey he's got it Ami's that make yours
look like you're ladies like you hey is
it Friday at Red Lobster
dudes surf and turf pop pop pop I know
that if I know that but you tend to look
like he's got a big nipple you tend I'm
straight hold on you got it Nick you got
a tip there's any other uh shirtless
pics maybe his legs make your legs look
a little bit awfully as you're doing
this I'm sorry I [ __ ] I'm embarrassed
hey bring his girl up there in that
mocha I'll go that one go that way well
she's she's fantastic
their kids are gonna be deliciously
beautiful hmm
I mean deliciously is terrible hey bring
them up let me see him in the air let me
see him in the vest pocket is there is
inaudible when I try to waterboard and
didn't do didn't have such good luck
kicking waterboard remember that we
couldn't have being bred in China for a
fool yeah I know we just couldn't get up
on the [ __ ] on the board no he's a
super stud man we should have him on the
show
yeah we should we should and now that
Ohio State remains the thing whiskey
brings out the game both of us doesn't
nobody I mean I sober her drunk I'm I'm
into this yeah you know there's a well
don't do that so there was a podcast
that Shepard did a podcast with Rob
McElhenney
and the dude who's on the Marvel they
meet the first Indian coming out
tomorrow tomorrow no Kumail Nanjiani oh
yeah
so those three did a podcast just on
men's body
insecurities and lifting weights and
it's fantastic Wow ITEX Rob I went
because they're Tama how much Dax are my
how he loves to see a good package
flopping around
so I set Rob the video of me and Rogan
we're time I they got around the 40s
dick flopping out that way here's the
greatest dick-slap you oversee in the
history of units right and that guy when
you run you and I know that your your
dick turtles up your dick is like I'm
going in
this guy was running full speed and his
dick floppy flop I mean it was like a
lot but like rabbit ears it's a great
podcast is that this is a well-built kid
yeah cuz they all talked about the
insecurities of their bodies and how
they feel fat even went and Rob was
saying how you know on when he did It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia in
Philadelphia he did belt so he did one
spectrum we got really fat for a role
that he wrote he's the writer right so
he wrote that he got really fat so just
eat whatever you want to get super fat
which is hilarious and then he did
another one we get super Jack I've seen
he got his chap bring up the rhyme Rob
look at he's got a great body
oh dude he got jacked but he was various
I mean that's crazy muscular but he was
saying how how into thinks he got he's a
special dude I don't know but he's
talking I got really special dude you
want about talent writing directing God
think that's all I miss you know he
sunny no I've never seen the show he's
from Philadelphia wrote the show look at
his body it's ridiculous why wouldn't
you always look like that well it's -
exactly I always look like that you
can't entertain that right yeah please
say now he's waking up me is dedicated
and but what are you saying I can't
thank you say this the in the baby he
looks phenomenal
he looks like [ __ ] Armor sword he
looks like jean-claude man yeah now now
was that a little help there
that's the only reason I didn't like the
pockets they don't talk about steroids
at all and I didn't appreciate it
because especially kymaro where the
[ __ ] name of male definite steroids
and come on Rob you definitely took some
[ __ ] dude sure but whatever you don't
bring you know I don't know now
daddy might go on that stuff we've been
talking about this you just do I want to
a woman I wish you would I know
maybe I'll try and convince Jay to do it
can't the lids get my legend can he be
ridiculously huge ace so way too big
Jay's got a great body he'll he'll be
stupid he'll be stupid thick how's that
nicotine treating its kid I think I'm
getting into it now if the four is a
little shot guy still a buzz yeah even
though I like I like that stuff nicotine
starts smoking weed I'm gonna get my
lids done it's gonna be great what a
great year it's gonna be
dude this nicotine start off I only did
it when I was riding the peloton in the
mornings because I heard Nick teens
really good for your brain for dementia
and CT so I'm like I'm gonna get on it
I don't want any the consequence is
reacting to it do you not yep I do know
that and take that yep and so started
doing that and but Audrey Marcus got me
started it but he sent me these they're
called vault I think and they're from
Sweden and they're extra strength too
powerful and then someone at one of my
live shows goes papa surf-and-turf
try this and get some much more mild but
tasty that's what I'm on now V lows you
do things without my consent or without
my know-how but now it might matter I
just find out you're doing these
nicotine patches no I do them all day
hold it hmm okay do you all know I have
a weird thing about all of this and you
know what it is I just figured it out
you know why I don't go on TRT sure I
don't do anything like that or just your
[ __ ] it's not that I'm a little bit
arrogant so what I do is I go like this
I go my immune system my natural state
is better than anything science could
offer us and I'm wrong psoriasis and all
my friendships is the worst I've ever
seen
well that was stress but all my friends
I called it all my friends are on
something except for you and but I mean
older friends what do you mean on some
well they're all doing you know and
they're all laugh at me and they go you
should do because you have no idea so I
feel like I'm gonna open a card and be
like oh you know but but then again I
don't need any more energy my dick and
cut a diamond right now that's what I
want to [ __ ] with I'm a mama I got I got
very good energy do you have the best
energy I do you can go I don't know if I
want to [ __ ] with things that take time
asking stuff or whatever ha people
politics now is long if I get 7 a half
hours sleep daddy doesn't mean nap
I go hard the other thing I do is I work
out but not too crazy where I don't have
injuries everybody I know who works out
too much there's something they always
get it right this you as an athlete know
this you know what I'll do is I'll do
I'll do it and then I'll just stop when
I feel like I want to that I don't want
Jesus look at my stomach without any TRT
at 50 no no you're a great body dude I
don't but you know hey I want you to
apologize for saying I was a
professional athlete in front of work
where well I'm sad of you being I can
hardly keep call me professor
look at my Bonnie I'm alright I didn't I
was there that night you're singing your
ass I did alright you did great you gave
me a bit of a compliment I went was I
good you went yeah you're the best
really the best by far the best thought
but it was I appreciate because you went
I didn't know if I was good or I didn't
I thought you went brother thought I was
great it was fun I filmed it it was
phenomenal and they asked me to do it
now the was it the def jam will find a
song for you I got the phone what is it
Dave Matthews dude into me Madeline
Jackson smooth sup Jackson Jack smooth
just Jackson Jackson why not by what I'm
sure say your full-name Jack words motor
surf and turf surf and turf or surf or
turf or listen to me right now LLL
accept your your your now listen Dave
Matthews is a vocalist now I I don't
need you trying to do Dave Matthews you
want me to do Queen you can't do that
you read your journey what are you
thinking where you going with this you
can't do those guys you don't think
probably need to make a very easy song
satellite in my eyes you don't think I
couldn't maritime dude hold on try that
on brother
let me see you sing this try it but take
it seriously
let me hear him sing it first satellite
I got here Dave do it and then I'll do
it I wouldn't know how Dave slave I
wouldn't do that no I
puts me in the river why you just hit it
Baba why you overthinking it but you're
thinking it that everything authentic
DMB you're overthinking it oh this is so
hard to plan guitar touch my top 10
Sundays yeah I'm super hard top 10 Brian
it's not on guitar town I didn't oh no
he says that's Dave plane
I wonder I could do this I can't do it
like Dave Matthews I'm saying for
karaoke I could stage
here's what gets tricky do you know what
I would do remix I think I would do this
I would rapping it no man I have Dave
Matthews voice and you lip-sync it but
nobody knows and I can do it you're gone
I can do it I don't here's God panting
Matt and you got it
no God no I got I don't do the whole
performance your chocolate jock jams
will they call it is it jock what they
call it performance with our boy does it
it's called the goddamn Comedy Jam
that's right but with Josh Adams Josh
atomizers who I love they've asked me do
it three times now and Papa just not
ready to come in Josh shoes yeah towns
is fantastic and you know who else can
sing their ass off to is Adam Ray who
does it all the time Adams a singer I
ain't but I can fake you can sing I can
fake some Dave Matthews I don't know
what else I'd do you could rap that's
always awkward
you could rap my rap I almost got in a
fight on the way here do you know that
Oh Wyatt this [ __ ] guy was driving
his bike
and I he was coming a little citrate no
he's riding a bike inside a [ __ ] I
could tell by his face he was a [ __ ]
I was like you're riding a bike that's
old you probably stole your [ __ ]
Hera's all [ __ ] okay yep
white guy about my age maybe a little
younger homeless no but a [ __ ] you
know just a general [ __ ] you go in
there and he's got he's got a he's my
age and he's got some ramen noodles and
a futon and he's got a [ __ ] mangy dog
he never walks always
you know that guy he smells like
mothballs all the time [ __ ] headless man
who knows what is that now he's just a
[ __ ] yeah one of those guys who
everybody think homeless and he [ __ ]
is crossing the street you say get a job
now he's crossing the street and I go
well you're not even crossing yet I'm
gonna pull I'm gonna I'm gonna cut off
from yeah yeah and yeah I knew he goes
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
sure and I stopped and I went I looked
at him and I went you want to start me
up [ __ ] you
oh now when I defense when I pop my [ __ ]
the [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I went [ __ ] you
and I never do that cuz he's crap I
don't give a [ __ ] about that guy crazy I
don't know why but I got mad at him I
went [ __ ] you ooh he stopped and looked
at me and I looked at him and I went do
so why oh yeah anyway huh his face
tighten up in each other man I kept
driving cuz I'm brave and then he I saw
him
yell at me afterwards I was like that
way oh yeah gave him the old bird and I
never do that either I don't know what
got into me I became I got sucked in his
energy because the whole bird things
like Sophie and I went like that in the
car yeah so those eyes right here to
shoot up the place
oh not only get mad on the rhodium or no
road rage now do you ever get mad in the
road I'm never I'm chill no I tell you
know what I had on food truck Diaries
food Kenny Florian I love Kenny love
them my son does jujitsu at school I
talked about yeah we talked about it
love Kenny Kenny such a smart cool dude
man told dr. Ken I don't know why
doesn't do like a video series every
week on YouTube like chill does breaking
up fights and stuff we don't hear from
him enough yeah you see doesn't really
use them as calm Taylor so [ __ ] his
jujitsu school was outstanding Meraki in
Santa Monica Barrington
I'm Santa Monica is fast he's rich
fashionable dude yeah came dressed to
impress definitely a first guest out
dress me and then he's also a huge
portion of guy he has a Porsche 964
loves his cars deal you don't told him
buy your car
well I heard he goes I heard he had that
car he can't he came and we did we
talked about cars and yes he had the you
know the gt3 for a while there and he's
a guy who PC up it looks like a regular
guy
that's exactly we talk about peace yep
yep if you're if you're a civilian and
you want to step to Kenny Florian it's
gonna be a long day for you smart man or
a short day actually short day oh yeah
short day he's a good man love Kenny ken
Florian Kenny the Ken flow he was saying
when he fought Josie out on food truck
they gave him two months and he was like
oh cool a fight jose aldo dude for the
time shop and i was out there doing
promotional work for the UFC during
canada things toronto and so i you know
i see him and he looked the closest to
death i've ever seen a baby being
because he goes dude i started my weight
get at 189 ah 145 oh my god oh my god
Jesus that's nuts
189 I more why not
where was that fight out Jose out on him
look at him there look at him there oh
that's so weird
two months before that he weighed
basically 190 that's so weird
oh he said he's that dude my my in camp
I was like hitting the bag like can
barely get no energy Oh then he had to
fight that nightmare I'm Ariel your I
favor the toughest small man I've ever
met in my life see 136 just type in you
see what a senator was right arriv
favorite share that we need to go to
Center Houston Texas
we fought Jose Aldo yeah
I had thought Canada but yeah I was
there doing promotional work great card
god that was nine years ago
bak times moving and I was [ __ ] movin
goddamnit some more this whiskey cloudy
my son's going to jujitsu today at
Kenny's place yeah Kenny didn't drive
his [ __ ] Porsche dude is this
old-school 964 that he's hooking up that
I was all excited to break it down on
the show
you lift the car pick him up if you uh
bought me a Porsche what would you buy
me
yeah Brian I got you I got you a gift
uh Panamera you know a Panamera us I get
you a 911 Targa I think it'll be sick
I'd like a Targa to be cool enough a
sticker automatic oh yeah well they
don't make them in sticks anymore the
only stick I can get you the gt3 touring
but again not for you when I appreciate
it you know but I like me buying you a
pair of they don't wear make them in
sick it's all everything they make a gt3
touring stick we can get a 911 are that
afford it but can't get it either
they're impossible to get Jerry Seinfeld
has one mm-hmm that's what I get show me
110 lease that's exactly should get do
please get that not a convertible though
right it wants a target so it so it's a
t-top you see it and you can close and
go but it's all glass Wow really yep
it's all glass the tops all its target
so they pop folds into glass on top do
please get that card right I'll get it
why not
well I wouldn't on that green we're
gonna getting a classic like that Korean
classic silver Porsche silver yeah Targa
4s I'm a fan of the old Porsche I'm a
fan I'll tell you what you look good in
man my Aston Martin not bad right
not bad now with the black Rams no nope
not for you I'll go I pick up pick one
up second man right no just lease a new
one why just lease it cuz you like it uh
you don't want to own you know like this
just lease it Targa Lisa from fighting
the kid let me drive it
company car okay right off half the
lease topless [ __ ] drives through now
and then there you go I like that your
car that's a nice-looking little card on
dude I'd like to drive around don't call
a little car dude Porsche little baby
don't oh man there's my man who don't
don't [ __ ] dude hey did your surf and
turf just keep talking like that you can
get the surf and the turf dude
hey bro bro I'm comfortable on my feet
and I'm comfortable in the - sure gotta
be honest with you sure I've never
opened up with you can i okay so here's
the thing no I know I know
you know our box but you're not afraid
of unboxing now now hold on all [ __ ]
aside if I open up with my feet hold on
I know you like to talk about your
Taekwondo days listen to me look at me
listen I over now with my feet like wand
oh yeah okay Taekwondo hey you have
Taekwondo - Taekwondo we get me what a
[ __ ] I will kick you know did I know at
your age when you when you're a kid yeah
losers
I hate to be shitty about it Lumis
[ __ ] we okay take your job hey you
know you know why you did Taekwondo why
did you come into anything else and I
hate to be shitty oh it's a rattler I
hate to be she rude I ever naturally
know why you guys did Taekwondo I cuz
there's nothing else for you dude my
wheel kick knows these Taekwondo back
then Oh [ __ ] whiskey don't drink life
don't dream what's going through your
old whiskey dude bro my back kick you
have no answer for my wheel kick you got
no answer for listen if you wanna move
this when I close distant you want to
get you want surf and turf you can get
surf and turf I will move this table a
little drunk I will move this table I
will [ __ ] you up I'm gonna trust a last
warning
I won't so I'm getting mad do all your
kicks you got your [ __ ] shoes on I
all right dude - I'm telling you be what
the [ __ ] dude this is this is 23 years
you're drinking a lot man and what I
yeah I am hey but I'm kind of drunk and
ornery no I'm not I'm just telling your
Taekwondo listen to me I hate it's about
time I drank this Estelle's
funeral hey hey [ __ ] you know who signs
up you know signs are kids up for
Taekwondo Oh
parents cuz they're careful anything you
know because you're coming out the
ground you better pull your chute right
now cuz the crowds coming fast pull your
chute oh yeah dude order the surf and
turf
cuz it's Wednesday and they we got a
special you know the special is it's
black and blue baby it's black and blue
a candle over black and blue dude my
elbows I got a lot of weapons at my
disposal I'll become leaner elbows ain't
Taekwondo that be more tired and you're
more tired no
doesn't exist you don't think I [ __ ]
study everything Jackson Jackson smooth
see ya you say what's cute say what
call me Jackson smooth I don't like
where you're going with this it's making
me mad and I'm a man I'm a proud man and
what are you doing right now what the
[ __ ] are you doing right now
call me Jackson smooth and if you feel
froggy dude and like I said if you want
to order the surf and turf we're open
for business are you stretching enjoy a
good whistle and you got a good with you
Peter athletic greens it's all I'm gonna
say you would be absolutely great you
gotta have greens near diet if you want
to be athletic
one thing health experts dieticians the
athletes top performance of ground is
that the perfect diet doesn't exist
everybody's different even with a
balanced healthy diet it can be tough to
cover your institutional base 72 live
vitamins in one single dress that's
where athletic greens comes in it's the
ultimate daily all-in-one health drink
with 75 vitamins minerals whole food
sourced ingredients very important
biology orbit enzymes they got it all
super fiber you gotta deliver it in
powder form I take it every damn morning
y'all and I've never felt better notice
I'm not sweating all the time am i dude
whether you're taking steps towards a
healthier lifestyle or you're an athlete
pushing for better performance athletic
greens gives you the nutrients you need
for your body to thrive tell me
correctly why not just try it taste why
not try it tastes good you can't just
eat surf and turf what you want to do
try it jump over to the athletic
greens.com slash fighter and claim the
special offer today a free tub of 20
servings of all-natural New Zealand
sorts hun percent grass-fed whey protein
with your first purchase
that's micronutrients and macronutrients
covered again go to athletic greens comm
slash fighter for your special offer
there's a reason top performers
entrepreneurs athletes and Olympians use
it do it if you want the best
supplements on planet earth if you want
a home gym if you want an online
exercise program we got you covered with
on it if you want kettlebells if you
want chimp bells if you want gorilla
bells if you want Star Wars mm-hmm if
you want battle room if you want food I
don't know elk bars when you're playing
when you're hunting if you want about
the [ __ ] yeah coffee dude keep
emphasizing on it
black rifle the two best of the best
decided to do a coffee and it has
caffeine crystals in it you know me dude
I'm one step away from trying meth in my
veins because coffee doesn't work
anymore but [ __ ] yeah coffee does it
gets me raring to go and you get 10% off
go to audit comm slash fighter for 10%
off everything MCT oil the almonds the
best of my face on it
they got freaking fat butter elf bars
Omega protein bars warrior bars joint
oil em CTO I've already said that twice
now it's that goddamn good [ __ ] yeah
coffee black rifle on it on it calm
slash fighter for 10% off the entire
damn website come on we're back we back
that was a great cuz we almost got a
little I almost got you don't get the
surf and turf yeah I almost I almost
ordered Reverend oh I almost threw a
flying in your [ __ ] face I would have
done it I really would have flying me in
your face now Julia hooked me up with
his stylist his fair girl let's go see
her today definitely canceling too far
though you know Hollywood far too far
Hollywood after three two bars only six
miles away she can take me and forever
change stand-up he'll take me out there
otherwise we got a problem
the only reason I go in there yeah it's
real some current events sure Jim what
you think of whiskey though I told you
it was really smooth amazing you know
was the best mascara and the
the warm the lovely warm feeling it's
the message what's this I was just
watching the noisy on post Malone yep so
this was submitted by Jay Brock - 955 on
Instagram with the Aryan scramble you
can't follow you there was a video from
one of post Malone's most more recent
concerts where a lot of people are
worried that he has a drug problem and
these are the clips that's why I'm two
years away from this video
[Music]
there's a new boy here no go back then
keep going up until about a rock start
doing rock star [ __ ] here well a lot of
dudes they once seemed do drugs as far
as I know he only drinks beer smoke
cigarettes that's why he came out and
said I have a friend who's very close to
him and I thought the same thing I go
dude how many drugs is young he goes
dude only drinks but life smokes
cigarettes I give you my word
yeah that's what he is well-known for
but a lot of people are concerned over a
lot of different artists overdosing that
when they saw him acting this way on at
his concerts they were worried that he
was on drugs he actually had to come out
and during the following concert after
this one he actually came out and said
that he's not on drugs and he had his
like on his like on tour photographer
come out and also say like nobody on the
tour does drugs all he does with the
terrible tattoos on his fastest bachi
well that's what the kids do face
tattoos yeah he's so talented yeah oh
why because he wrote songs for cut youth
before he's a writer for Kanye West Oh
papa he writes all original songs his
song with Ozzy Osbourne and he found the
guitar he's ridiculous ask me how you
learn to play guitar himself that but
Guitar Hero oh he has video him on
guitar you ripping it up and he goes I
was really good on there I post it and I
was like do I gotta learn the real thing
Wow I have something yeah so then you
learned the real guitar so real musician
people just have that he's so talented
he's stupid talented he's a writer so he
started as a songwriter for Kanye West
he sold songs for cut a bunch of guys
look it up Jim but he wrote songs sold
to Kanye I forget who else but I bought
like big big name artists start off as a
writer Wow he came to LA with his buddy
cuz buddy was a youtuber and was a dude
they're all from Texas that I dude we're
gonna go to LA and try and see if we
make it because they were doing YouTube
videos so he goes I don't have any money
can't come with you
Angus but can you help me out did you
make him after YouTube because I had no
money so every day would scrounge around
like four quarters and change to buy
cigarettes and Bud Light and
and start with his buddies would do like
the twitch stream like you and he'd be
in the back playing they're like [ __ ]
with people and then he got on there
playing guitar hero and then wrote his
own album called white Iverson it was
like I'm just gonna release it everybody
goes dude don't release it wait yes I
don't have any money I'm dead broke I
need to get this out there put it out
there he goes ten times platinum oh my
god and now he's post below oh my god is
that good he's a savant holy [ __ ] he's
very good he's got a great voice he's
he's just he's just very very unique
yeah yeah very very gifted musically
songs written by post Malone's is that
did that show it no I liked him without
tattoos yeah you know what the tattoo
says always tired yeah so yeah but up
now now the carnivore died wouldn't hurt
him got a little weight on
yeah it's that beer man drinking those
empty calories do ya but I'll skip I
don't give a flying [ __ ] it dude he
gives a [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah maybe it
depends everybody cares about how they
look especially I got like this well
yeah I don't know if he cares physically
like about his like physique some guys
don't give me fine [ __ ] good-looking guy
there though I like the way it looks
with that long hair right there with a
cigarette in his mouth usually here's a
cool style yeah it but you know it's
just for him he'd be tough some of it
like he is his style is very cool he
looks cool when he wears like jackets
and like his tattoos yeah he's a
musician he's creative artist yeah yeah
didn't need the tattoos can just be to
help I wish he would tell you styles
cool I love his stuff now my big ass
where's that the Reavers ago Jesus
you're gay slim there you used to be
thin but then you start doing you know
all that beer I've got those empty
calories huh tattoo hands yeah that's a
lot that's a lot of commitment
not a work it's to get a little whiskey
problem oh it's so good
you've had a lot of whiskey no look at
both of them so fun it's a lot of well
well you had some of this no no it was
up to here hold on
you had to hear hablas drink beer
drinking gin you've had two bottles no
chin it started here that's a beautiful
ski chin has being careful with this
whiskey I'll sit here and then you hear
this whiskey is not to be drunk that way
it's special drink out of the bottle
though oh yeah yeah that's gonna last
you a couple days or maybe one day this
on tour would last Friday night that's
it you drink the whole thing
yep it's that good you can drink a whole
bottle whiskey and you know I'm fine
your big bowl next day I'm fine boy yeah
we gonna do the giant what else you got
Centauri is that were you doing chin
where you're just looking up Japanese
whiskey Wilson certain how santori's of
fine whiskey Japanese whiskey - very
poised Satori I've had it many times it
doesn't even it's not even the area code
it's not in the area bring it up into
Nakia Nika Nika Nika Crawford he could
calm anything like that's my that's my
favorite that's my go-to can I go too
besides Buffalo Trace so hold on we're
playing because coffee grinds might go
to nazma and I'm making it anymore for
whatever reason no they are I heard
they're not really just continually
about it no no no they get by that you
should date you but Nika car grants $69
and I got it's my go to me to this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] this 800 once you get that
Hibiki 30-year that's a biggie I've had
a heavy because I do whiskey yeah but
even Hibiki is great but it's not I had
the Hibiki 17 sir I'm telling you I'm
I've had all my boy whisky peed been on
his tried the best ways in the world
nothing beats this it's the best whiskey
I've ever had
23:09 Mikado single grain whiskey
Bushido city key is overrated because
I've had the 17 and I've had the 12 I
think I'm had although hey binky's I
haven't had the 30 you're not ready for
that but oh no this that's the best
whiskey okay so Shack lost a bet to
Dwyane Wade and he had to let his
hair grow out and show his hairline on
national television and this is what it
looks like let's just get it out the way
America I had very good one of my good
friends d-wade Milwaukee versus the heat
I said Milwaukee was gonna win by 20 in
the heat one I said well what do you
want me to do pay you said not the heat
again you gotta let your hairline grow
we want to see your hairline looking
like Kenny Smith oh he looks like Steven
he's got a great sense of humor
oh they're hilarious he looks like
Steven Naismith students with spore head
like it goes all the way back mm-hmm
don't look at me like that I don't start
with that I have great hair and I'll get
another hair transplant right now my
lids done hair transplant
- when are the when the [ __ ] are they
gonna come up with stem cells for her
hurry up is he right it's terrible it's
just agent Angelo you say strange he's a
bad man
I love him he's already dumped box o him
it's eating him it's don't post it post
it remembers first time saw you hit
Matty quit so take it easy
what do you mean I quit remember dude
yet tell a nice pardon I got tyonne
everyone's sparring I was like yeah but
I mean it's a language it's just doing
it yeah yeah what are you doing when
you're working monday through saturday
you don't have a lot of time that hit
mid there's a 55 year old man I don't I
don't know who gives a [ __ ] right now
that's all my him not you yet what else
you got
okay so last week your boy jared leto
posted up a couple of photos and a video
of him rock climbing where he says that
he almost died because part of his rope
started to fray while he was a couple
hundred feet up dude dear God don't take
him and by a couple I mean 600 [ __ ] holy
[ __ ]
it was spraying right at the point and
then if you go up that is the photo
hilarious [ __ ] he's fine
I know but that's pretty [ __ ] he's
fine also stop rock climbing although I
would like to
but also he's fine I know but that is
scary hangs from a mountain with that
security but 600 feet 600 feet Jews yeah
drop at 600 feet it was frame like the
casing frayed the actual rope did do
that [ __ ] was cold you don't have to
rock course you didn't you don't matter
rock like hey wait I've never done that
excuse me he's in Utah legitimate I
spent your rock-climbing obsessing over
it one year yeah cool dude I did freeze
tank for a year climb to 511 and I got
pretty good do you have any videos
anything you have show me a pic I don't
do that oh but show me a pic I've never
happened I did that I never happened on
a rock climb look at my finger did
lettle rock climb look at my fingers I'm
better I'm a better rock climber with
him right now
right now he's DC in his body I have a
better body no I don't have a better
body but I'm better gritty hope you do
things wrong everything better
he didn't come close to dying so let's
be very clear there all right dude we
almost let off
we don't get off dude you keep clown Jay
Leno order the surf and turf and guess
what Wednesday's is black and blue plays
hey bro again watch your [ __ ] tone
Jackson because I am not in the mood and
I will meet you [ __ ] halfway and keep
you tre busy trail Oh Cupid preocupe a
which means very busy in French okay
you saw the rock climbing up on my shoes
my tail QP you see the rock climbing
rope on my ops why those stupid couple
take that off and choke the [ __ ] outta
you'll try as I always say to my
opponents you'll try hey hey Bubba hey
hey papa
why all you got to do is call up the
waiter you're looking at him at Red
Lobster
order the surf and fluff in turn and it
comes
hey you're a comes hot a little afraid
of you right now that surf and turf come
off yosity hey hey hold on this urban
turf comes ready sizzling hot now you're
deep you're about five drinks hey hey
all you should be hey hold on that
serpent do you like the crab biscuits
they're great right yeah sure
that's the order here's the thing yeah
that surf and turf comes sizzling hot
yeah so what would you what do you think
you're gonna what do you think you're
gonna do when we're standing toe-to-toe
see when I do this my Denzel Washington
yeah yeah let me see this because I'm
feeling hot oh yeah I don't want you
leach allenge because what happens is I
gotta meet the challenge and you got
skinny legs my boy right we know that
hey Bryan
dude what order surfacer now you gonna
say is hey all you gotta say is I'll
take the surf and turf Jackson Smith say
those words say those words say Oh save
I'll take the surf and turf Jackson
smooth and it's on don't like me in
talents is a man hey man we're old man
all I'm saying all you have to do yeah
if you want to get fed today if you want
to get fed all you guys all you gotta do
is say Brendon I will have the surf and
turf please and thank you everybody
drinks it Jackson smooth you a drink I'm
not I'm being real with you
and the problem is my set my reactions
are a little dull yep so sure so are my
daddy daddy's daddy's little daddy into
tussle right now hey daddy why all you
have to do is say Jackson smooth can I
have the surf and turf and I'm gonna
come in sizzling hot is you ordered it
because you ordered it and I'm here and
I'm ready
hey Jackson up dude don't do it Brian
dude I've warned you and now you're
drinking water dude don't do it
Jeff get over the surf and turf I'll say
the words right say the words
Jackson smooth can I have the surf and
turf
dude order the surf and turf I'm not
gonna do it unless you're the surf and
turf if you were in serve turf you're
gonna get it and second come [ __ ]
Sizzlin you've had you've you've had the
crab they say the words it's like
beetlejuice
say the words and I come [ __ ] in
flying hot and you know it's a nice dish
I want to order the surf yep and Smurf I
said Smurf I didn't say turn all right
no I don't know surfing Smurf okay no
don't do it
Brendan Brendan let's move on okay
that's cuz he's just a little too drunk
for the [ __ ] around not when the matter
gets drunk it gets a little worrisome
109 dollars about for good old cat oh my
god everyone's a bunch of draw a hundred
and nine dot what a bunch of [ __ ] and
by the way that infectious disease guy
said doesn't really work it that that it
does the illustrious no he said that the
the washing your hands against
coronavirus doesn't really work because
guess what you know you catch it you
ready for this everybody right breathing
breathing breathing so I should wear the
mask and that he said that's [ __ ] -
I've always said that he said the only
thing that would work there's a special
kind of mask you were that that's a
respirator they used for asbestos very
effective walk around like that like an
[ __ ] hey can I tell you something I
don't trust that guy what's he think
gender well so you talked the entire
pockets like this yeah he look like
postman my joke is I'd rather catch
coronavirus I don't wear a mask on the
planks I'd rather catch coronavirus
looks like a [ __ ] and I'll tell you
something those things are totally
ineffective against catching coronavirus
yes so now they might stop you from
giving it to somebody but you're gonna
have it yeah here's the other thing -
ever made this great point - I don't
take credit for it
I've been sick since January I I was so
sick and on Tauron on to Ontario I think
I was in February I was so sick dude you
were weren't you I was so sick now did I
have Corona and didn't get checked for a
because they weren't checking for it
back then I have
I had a doctor come but they they
weren't checking for were you
nighty-night virus Ontario but but then
I went to Papua went to Vancouver pop
wants Antonio all I do is live on planes
so did I have Corona cuz at my age you
just get a sore throat you get real sick
you don't die ain't killing surf and
turf baby yeah taking the surf and turf
oh no not taking surf and turf out now
now did I have it and I just didn't do
no cuz you know who didn't get it my
kids my girl got it super sick I got
swine flu kept going kept going got
[ __ ] up cuz it swine flu you'd get
sick then you'd get better then and come
back it come roar and back and you get
even worse I got so sick I'm telling you
I haven't felt right since January damn
well my dad said I was like I feel a
little sick because I'm usually healthy
and he goes hey nobody's healthy all the
time nobody not all the time but 90% of
time yeah
doom well I'm really good I've been
really lucky but but yeah but you've
been sick since January in one where and
I haven't felt right since January
really feel - I'm just dying are you
sleeping enough oh yeah but you haven't
felt right what do you mean energy
lineman oh my Energy's fantasti I'm
think since night Energy's fantastic oh
no I work out on the bottom top my nose
always bunched up I've never feel 100 so
again pop up if you're hungry all you
gotta say
Jackson smooth I want the surf and turf
yeah he's gonna come yeah
and now what are you gonna do it's
buttered up watch it's buttered up what
say you know what do it's sticky
huh they get sticky oh yeah yeah yeah
let me tell you something right the only
reason I'm not [ __ ] fighting you
right now sure is because I have to be a
little careful a longneck is always a
little iffy hey how about this surf and
turf won't touch your net you got a
bunch of other joints I like to get my
hands on I'm not afraid of that at all
sure I'm not afraid how's your ankles
how's your knees how's your arms you're
not getting to them how's the move on
your shoulder you have shoulder problems
yeah you do no I'm fine all right sir
turf like the keep hazing hey sir turf
I'll take him for a ride
I'll punch you sure dude Porter the
surfers back on track I know you will
yeah dude and I've ordered the surf and
rock you a red lob we'll just say the
words like you're making me mad three
times say it three times like
beetlejuice and I'll play you want to
play I'm gonna I'm an arcade game
promise you have [ __ ] battles and
you're deep you're a half-bottle in
almost no what do you talk dude
Chin's had Jess you've had this had a
ton of whiskey next current event like
Beetlejuice say it three times
oh well maybe I will you guys heard this
Harvey Weinstein 20 years right he's
gonna die soon fantastic what a great
ending for 23 years in prison it's a
good an for B [ __ ] you know what do you
want to bet
Jackson smooth air money that man dies
within the next year I'd say next six
months Dobbs Lee right oh you mean
murder public here's too much dirt on
Hollywood
oh you mean I don't know about that cuz
I guarantee you he commits suicide in
Sanibel screw your yeah she was the
rider left am i right he got she got
raped by him mmm and I believe every
single one of those women man yeah me
too the girl the [ __ ] monster she was
the most beautiful one all right dude
Lauren young all members Lauren came
with the hat that monster is that the
only 3/4 they say six women touch man
yeah that's just a mop in 23 years they
threw the book he's appealing but good
luck
your boy Takashi six nine are things
getting out in August damn he is and and
and doesn't want witness protection how
long before the who dies first him or
Harvey I'm gonna say mmm I'm gonna say
Harvey
model prisoner so yeah August now I'm
Akashi 6/9 fan I liked how he trolled
all the other rappers
he did but he went you just got too deep
into it yeah he'd make fun of all the
rappers like that [ __ ] done and you'd go
cuz yeah all the rappers threatened him
all the time he goes hey
I'm in New York would give his address
go you talk all this [ __ ] come on down
I'll see he's tiny can't fight has the
worst body in the way yeah have you ever
seen his music it is why take off your
shirt it's making it okay to be kind of
skinny fat but he would rip there is he
would really his body there and his
belly buttons disgusting it's so hairy
but he would look at him what is that
what is that range cat very strange cat
he made it and they got to deep tried to
be a thug you not a thug no now his girl
tattooed his face on her neck so that's
cool his girl's hot too
oh she is smoking now can we talk a
little bit as a current event about
Logan Paul giving Paul Acosta some some
some some business on the wrestling no
wrestling yeah they were sparring and
looks fake to me I did that which-which
wrestling video did you see them
sparring though no I still think people
were looking there I'm telling you the
bully rests on the Ohio which is a
breast arrest on college in high school
but he was like all Allstate I bet he's
no higher which is a big it's like being
all say he was like a super d watch says
Bobby oh you'll appreciate this watch
the wrestling cause I'm telling you man
look ourselves a freak athletically it
does the knockout part but wrestling in
their house the whole is res log
impressive in fact it caught now it's a
Logan Paul verse Dylan Danis boxing
match there's no C in Brazilian - watch
this watch this wrestling
[Music]
wait go back go back go back go back go
back I got a guy who's speaking owns
jungle fights in Brazil by shocked him
tell single leg that's a wizard
it's [ __ ] no joke he's wrestling very
well here he is
look at him dude he wrestled in high
school at t-ball stay power cost has
problem that he was all Satan but Paul
costs not a wrestler dude yeah he was
Allstate in Ohio like that's some
serious credentials as far as high
school he's now he's a legit athlete you
say I'm telling you what you know me on
my hadron yeah he's a [ __ ] athlete
yeah I think Kimber still and Dennis and
the blocks in that big and strong strong
and also a smart dude yeah it's not an
accident he makes whatever 24 million
dollars year off YouTube it's not an
accident he's you know he's doing these
boxing matches that's it he can do
anything he he could do a foot race and
people with tuned in he doesn't have to
fight while II do is fire him back in a
jungle fight you gotta fight in Brazil
he's the Dana White a jungle fight oh I
didn't know yeah Wow no you know smart
dude
this is not that recent and in February
but Britney Spears she posted a video on
Instagram and then she breaks her foot
so you guys can actually see when it
happens to but look at her dance it's a
little weird but it looks a little
sloppy
where's the brake Oh
you
get ready still got that body
Wow
have you ever broken ankle or foot it's
coming up soon
where'd you two dance of the song yeah
remember she went crazy
oh I think she still is that a tenor
there beat all the all the bone but all
the bone yeah you know you [ __ ] the bone
snap like that unless isn't the Keeley's
which you would have said but Achilles
pops loud
I broke a little bone in my [ __ ]
ankle and didn't know it until after I
was done wrestling in that and then I
try to stand on have you ever like broke
your ain't like broke your ankle
no sometimes I break in your ankles
better than rolling it is breaking they
can it's gonna heal and they're not yeah
and you roll Yankel really bad ankle has
a memory and it never responds again the
same way really it's better to break it
than to roll it really really because
all the time they have a memory in the
end they get all [ __ ] up and then they
never they're scared is like this weird
memory oh but that the ankle huh yeah I
always find that injuries are so weird
cuz why is it that every time I get sick
or I get a twisting eye it's the same
injury in my neck I have a weakness for
compromise there's also 50 no no but but
I'm saying that that happened probably
when I remember wrestling when I was
doing jujitsu when I was 33 or something
yeah I would do something I go [ __ ] my
neck and I'm done for a week I don't
know but there's a we I hope there's
something there's some there's some kink
in your own yeah when I get a cold or I
have a flu where do I feel like my lower
back and my that right there like that
area is strange
that's so they say AIDS patients when
you get sick the areas that you had
injuries in inflamed oh wow
yeah that makes sense yeah
[ __ ] weird yeah I feel I don't family
that have any that how's your neck fine
I was there when you [ __ ] it up and
now you're fine I know then trust brown
they didn't way worse at one of my see
seventh or whatever is just dead it's
black is that true but yeah but I feel
fine I have no issues it's all the
exercise it's not you know I don't not
an owl Brian but it's alright I don't
know why don't you know what else yeah
this one's also not super new but it was
all over LA this hit hit and run ish
type of accident it was road rage I'll
tell you what the story afterwards but
this is what Haley Eilish did she
release the hush puppies why yes yes she
did her first concert on her world tour
in Miami Lisa she had a there was like a
small break-in in the performance where
she basically had a projection playing
of her taking off her jacket and then
she took off her shirt it was just her
and like a bathing suit oh [ __ ] do we
have video of that there's video so
here's the thing my chin older guys
another thing Billy Isla she doesn't be
known for her curves and like sexuality
so she always wears baggy clothes we
can't tell what's going on
but Papa has the eye right surface the
eye you knew I know there's some [ __ ]
sweater props some huge fat [ __ ] tear
there that's not her I have no idea oh
yeah but she did a video releasing the
hounds oh no just that one
no well it's a bat too still from the
video so yeah it's basically what it is
it's bra it's a video of her kind of
like taking off for sure and showing her
boobs in a bikini top basically saying
that if like she always gets judged for
her body regardless of whether she shows
it or not well good for her she's a
baddie I mean where where is uh where's
the video I'm clicking on do we have the
bikini yeah yeah oh you don't we need
Clara is you know how you pay me for the
style bender bet yeah and people don't
think I paid you for the rerun our
weight bet we've always paid
each other yeah the only bet we've never
paid each other on it's like those Oh
now if we all had million oh I have we
paid each other you [ __ ] the tattoo no I
hate each other we also give each other
like like we've given each other money
in certain situations where it just made
more sense I would outside my house well
that's my own house I told Brian wait
hey can I have all the funds for the
next three months friends kids don't put
down a fat [ __ ] I don't think about that
yeah we don't think like over you Brian
paid juba you Intel how about this we
always end because we we are accounting
was [ __ ] up I was I was using an ATM
machine I was literally I was I was
stealing money for me I was using the
finite thing as a slush fund yes I Oh
God knows how much how are you you know
I I kind of own you know some your
wife's horses I own half your Tesla
sorry which I want to get rid of I
didn't know I just sent two because you
got to get the [ __ ]
what's my next car we already covered it
dude you're getting the target yeah and
we're gonna make it a fine kid company
car did you drive it I Drive it it's
half your lease payment I guess just do
it well you have turned the Tesla oh
she's - I'm Tony sweater copies brah
she's so bad
[Music]
[Applause]
gorgeous Jesus what are those triple G's
enormous those in double D's all day
oh sure you take it off she's of age B
we're good today gorgeous girl Oh
phenomenal in such a talent course I
love her green hair are you a fan cat I
love her I love her I love her why do we
love her I think she's very she's very
much like she does what she wants and it
feels very authentic I like it that's
her and her brother people don't give
her brother enough credit I think he's
actually the mastermind behind the
lyrics and the they both write he also
produces all the music listen man he's
being an 18 or everybody's looking at
every [ __ ] detail your body yeah I'm
looking at it right over and she started
when she was really young - she got
popular when she was like 13 yeah I was
a fan he said that she was she became
very well-endowed at a young age and so
because she had all that attention on
her let's be honest when you're young
yeah like a booty cuz like her the one
girl in our school just had these how
awesome that was kids do these middle
school Mustangs yeah these middle school
Mustangs and middle school Mustangs and
I would jack off to her after school
I've been it must be tough though well
it's also like the same kid that's like
the kid who's 14 with his chops and a
beard you like out your [ __ ] dude yeah I
know you're killing it right now
in Overland a but after this it gets
very sad for you I've been in situations
where I Drive the girls in bikini we're
hanging out she had the greatest but I
walked up and then we took the bra off
dude things went things went south will
South Gotham will the Tidrow but they
also they were so and now they're done I
just quit on the job I go oh I'm sorry
are you flying Sal I mean are you on sir
are you a duck one is hanging to the
right and the other ones going I don't
care you know I asked him I asked him I
go hey are you Dutch she was white dude
tits are flying south yeah every time
yeah I was like but they used to be when
the beguine there and I know that's what
not
boobs look like Oh Cincinnati Isis that
are I love natural boobs I don't mind a
little saggy I like my boobs sometimes
some girls unfortunately have floppy
some nice things National National
Geographic it's an interesting situation
for them it's tough dude I like my
tunings natural - dude I prefer natural
dick Bryan we know this I like my teeth
like you like my strawberries fake like
I don't like fake tits
dude have you ever seen a real like a
nice well done fake ass like a Brazilian
butt I don't like this either because
you you you've never expected one yeah
well look I I'd like something natural I
love I love a natural woman I like I
like natural tits way more than like
fate this by far even with sag I don't
have any problem just sometimes
sometimes people have an unfortunate
situation what's going on it's like a
guy who's a great-looking tall handsome
pulls out his rod and it sure just it's
just short thin short then I've had
friends I'm [ __ ] startled my hog
they're so and they show me some stupid
video and I'm like not that's I I will
[ __ ] tower over you right now
you were sure you dwarf for sure no make
sure the fans are well okay that you're
not talking about your boy this is what
you do it see what you're doing is
you're kind of flirting with the idea
before in surfing terrific yeah okay
good salad you talking about me take it
as you are
Oh again order it dude take it easy all
right I'm just saying all right but hey
crazy take it easy all right all right
dude for a second that I've kind of felt
it no I know and you were worried about
me saying that you're your wiener
is it your it's well done but don't act
all like like that you're fine I saw
well dude you saw lit in the bathroom
right now like you peace wouldn't when
he's perched up when he's angry there's
a little bend to him and I like that Ben
come on I don't I don't have a curved
knob as he's working this is working
this way into anger he tends to wake up
with a little like you know what a a
whale shows you just the top of it's
just the tip you come out just at the
whales crest yeah you're your piece of
the
and somehow the middle part wakes up
first
I got you got the middle part it's like
a construction it's like your concern
here what is my back first in this there
you go then he goes alright I'll come
out of the water and at first he's like
I'm gonna bring my move and we got a
little bend
nothing bad yeah you're a fat dick it's
well-documented as well I do well we
both do music Taliah I've seen his dick
fully erect we were doing tamanna
podcast and he was hiding behind at in
the door jamb and I just saw him his
dick came out of the door of course he
was joking he worked with ZZ yes and he
was making it go up and down and I got
to tell you he's got us both beat she's
got both beat he's got a straight-up
fantastic shaft the kids got girth he's
got like the Lea does very very well he
does very well so and I went Chris
you're showing me your hard dick right
now and we have to do 10 minute podcast
do remember was Chris the stuff no I
showed you the picture we're gonna meet
him on a group chat with Jack Santino
and he goes morning fellas
it was just his [ __ ] like his [ __ ]
hidden like this barstool sports shirt
me us good morning fellas ago dude don't
send your dick to me because very well
it also do impressive in it was thing
I'll find it then but I took a long days
take his arse think you know what he is
he if this is a race he's third to you
and me I'll give you the girth here no I
knew well I'm too he's three but I I
think we'd have in your balls there's
one one you've all got some [ __ ] are
long ran all the balls and I lied like
your balls
I got heavy nuts I got a big old sack
now listen people like to suck on them
okay sure girls like suck on your balls
sure those long balls in my place put
them over their nose like Turk like a
turkey I've had I've had girls through
it all yeah why would it de Lappe
they're so floppy go to town my building
hole huh Oh buddy holes fun yeah it's
all a disaster
but I I that's that your girl Friday
night your balls her nose like this and
you ever do the Trojan helmet let's put
your [ __ ] rock let them you ever do
that you replace partner I don't do that
you never have her pretend she's
Leonidas no I never did 300 nope nope
with a thick mask I never did that
oh wow you missed that I know I'm
probably missing out but in in I don't
some eyes are watching porn and the guy
be like yes piss on all of it well does
it but also he loses his stuff all over
there watch a and he goes don't wipe it
off get out of here yeah and these I
don't like oh no yeah I don't know my
buddy said you my buddy said to me my
buddy said to me so you can tell why
your friends who are into a certain
things my buddy goes I like that guy not
sure I go why cuz he's a porn star he
goes cuz nacho nacho had the girl on the
stairs and he was banging her and yes
foot on her face i blue not to lows but
true I don't know why you'd be in there
man stepping on a girl's face that's
what you're into you psycho [ __ ]
he's like I didn't blow to buzz for free
and I went good so you say blow also
don't put your face on girls I guess
foot on her face as he was taking and
giving her the old on the staircase
which I can understand how you could do
that in from a gymnastics point of view
but I don't want to step on a guy's face
I like girls face crushes oh yeah yeah
yeah what else you go so you know you
can tell a lot about a friend he might
feel like I told you about my friend I
told you this story and I said on stage
but I'm gonna say it here where my
friend you never want to get an ax
you never want to get in a conversation
with a girl who has a longtime boyfriend
if your friends and they're breaking up
oh don't talk to the girl because she'll
give up the goods on your friend Yeah
right I had a girl I knew a girl one
time and she said he's a piece of [ __ ] I
said well you know he's my friend and
she goes and I'll tell you something
else he doesn't [ __ ] me or what I wrote
but he likes me to [ __ ] him
we have to stop Wow I'd already talking
about it she goes well he likes do I
know this guy he pegged okay you don't
have him at her but you'll know who he
is when I tell him uh and he liked it he
likes it a peg him and I went I can't
hear this right now I have to run away
yeah some people like to get I know a
very famous actor who apparently likes
to get his really his but give us some
movies then I don't want to give him out
cuz I like him I know but she give me a
movie even if he was like second-rate
movie like I wanted to do a cameo in it
I'll tell you later though
rhyme it with something for me what edit
it up I'm not soft no he's okay he's
okay he's a very good whiskey because
I'm not sauced no it's a fine whiskey
beautiful now if it was like Johnny
seems like you I need some food after
this can we eat or no I can eat I
wouldn't mind a hoagie I can't have fun
juice down our you know juice it well I
I can order the turkey from Jamaica that
brisket do you hear that bird visitor
forever time is it oh it's almost 3:00
traffic Papa Papa yeah that's kind of
that oh this is the road racing I'll
sign him up in North Hollywood I'll tell
you what happened afterwards but this is
Ben baller posting about it oh I like
Ben bond yeah that's cool oh my god
that's road rage yeah check it out and
that's an that's a nice beamer to on
that truck catches up to him first of
all that the seventh series being kept a
great car he's just he's just going
right down the streets and does the
truck driver get out no but I'll let you
keep watching
there's no where's one angle there's no
upside there's no angle now what happens
to BMW guy I'll tell you he's fought
before this this truck skin but also
smart okay now it's part one of the
craziest Road ragers you seen right well
first of all if you get out that F
that's that seven series wants to kill
you hey guys I'll see legit crazy what
do you guys think happened I don't know
any idea at all I would imagine somebody
spit on somebody else's car no so that
truck actually hit the Beemer and tried
to take off oh there you go yeah so the
Beemer just went off all you trying to
crazy
yeah so the Beemer guy got arrested and
was he illegal no he's like a big person
humor guy got arrested even though he
got hit yes and kid you can't do that
that's the problem you can't do that
look it looks like Gronk is doing WWE
yeah that was another one too
he's doing Doug Dewey close to signing a
contract with him so well I guess not
steroids at all that he's tackle you
talk about pepperoni back
oh yeah the CEO do somebody order the
ziti Wow yep there it is Wow how big is
drunken kill on steroids
yeah do stores in fwe that's gotta do it
I think you like you sign the contract
comes with like Decca
comes back oh um yeah well if that's
what Grunk wants to do yeah in who you
want to do one more you guys good not
good I do what else you got alright good
podcast Brian thanks for the 2000 up
them now it's Bert on next week so we
surprised save a bottle who for me in
Christ you're in this just use this one
then
no you take that home Jim thank you
here's another one this is a San
Bernardino County Sheriff she's very
pretty I seen her before but check out
some of the weather scary crash you have
to see this it's all caught she's found
more just never before I missed it I
missed it you have to see this it's all
caught on cell phone video
she's so good cross the street can man
bring her up push that you see what's
what
wait let's just see crazy this happen
Linda that's nuts show me a honky hey
what's your damn crash she probably says
her name I think she's in LA I see her
every morning you do I'm necessary
before every morning she's so special so
foxy loving I've been [ __ ] them in hot
record Mart the deputy was responding to
the sefer names poplar got away all
right Fox 11 News there's gonna be a ton
of hot ladies huh yeah I'll trust me
she's the number one dude that's her all
finesse
Joe special she is gorgeous I mean she's
she's super model that does the news
yeah let's go ahead and take a look at
her
just hit images before for Instagram
scrim no it won't be the same
yeah well yeah well she was a kid bummer
while she post about other people okay
Oh what am i doing what click it on the
man in the middle let me see what's
going on there picked up this stud in
his boat on the red carpet Chris Borgo
good-looking dude God look at her body
good what else we got
[ __ ] is going on I don't look on his
phone now here images yeah she's like a
model she's phenomenal
good [ __ ] oh that's her what the man
Wow
well I'm I think he's a stud - Wow
Wow oh no that's ones whoa God look at
that is it ten G's a ten yeah the camera
tip answers our tongues like this as I
thought deliciously beautiful oh is that
her in a bikini well she's the finest
now all the world that's another woman
and she's oh that's a Victoria's Secret
model
her name is damn just cloudy done well
let's move on for we in trouble all
right this is just oh this is how he
might know showing up to America's Got
Talent
that's the way he does he's it's cute
he's a germaphobe he's always funny you
know him a few are really close really
close yeah if you get the advice from
all the time like Howie they did a show
together a long time ago a game show
since then they've been really close how
is a good guy and he's foster ste at
this point Ryan understood
all right well listen kids see me in
Kansas City April 3rd and 4th come up is
Ohio April 17th and 18th Charlotte April
23rd 24th 25th I'm not trying to let the
dick out of the undies before too soon
but in the summer might be Kalin
maybe Santino might be Bobby Lee might
be Brendan shot my penis floor together
three City don't get embarrassed I beat
Chicago theater I don't know we'll
figure it out yeah I'm in Atlanta this
Friday there's a hundred tickets left
Atlanta bucket theater Corona can suck
my [ __ ] Atlanta bucket theater this
Friday one show only then Saturday night
I'm in New Orleans at the Fillmore that
thing needs some help
I can't lie to you guys Fillmore in New
Orleans need some help you know one it's
a weird market comes late let's do it
they're canceling the [ __ ] parade so
come on down
I'm right off of what's the big street
there bourbon I'm right off Bourbon
Street at the Fillmore New Orleans come
and get it Dark Arts people New Orleans
this Saturday
next week Austin those shows almost sold
out again Texans don't give a [ __ ] about
Corona Texans Austin I'm at cap cities
Thursday Friday Saturday that is March
19th through the 21st and I end the
month of March in Toronto that's almost
sold out within my own second show
Toronto March 26 Detroit March 27th
Minneapolis March 28th and then April
I'm going across the pond again ain't
nobody scared of Crona all these shows
I'm gonna sold out Cork Belfast Dublin
car Glasgow Newcastle Birmingham
Manchester London Cardiff and Amsterdam
Sweden and Norway got canceled do the
coronavirus the rest you see you find
[ __ ] countries are fantastic I love
you guys New York is almost sold out
that's May 7 8 at the Gramercy Theatre
with some special New York gas alright t
frack AECOM 4 tickets for brian myself
you can get your thick boy hoodies you
can get your sweet tart and tart and ass
hoodies teas anything fake boy related
tea fat cake aam merch store those
things are selling like crazy we love
you guys thank for the support this
Friday Atlanta Saturday New Orleans get
your tickets t5k calm the whole merch
shop is poppin Liddy like a titty bra
brother
hey or did the serpent alright this the
fire kid we're out